We'll just start out
with this basic thing where
I can use file inputs to
upload anything that I'd like,
which is cool.
But this whole
request was asking
if we could add a
capture attributes
to fileinputs to enable--
what was it again Barret
to basically enable the
front facing camera?
Yeah, to enable the
camera, the input.
There is already an excepts
argument to file input.
There was not the
capture attribute.
Right.
So fileinput has
handful of arguments
and accept allows us to
upload various different types
of files, is that?
So we could say accept
is image slash star,
so that you can
only upload images.
You wouldn't be able to upload
a CSV or something like that.
I see.
I say except video
image slash star.
Now if I run this
again, you can do your--
I can upload my P&amp;Gs but I
can't upload anything else,
you know, like PDFs.
Cool.
OK.
Right.
So and if we actually look at
the return value of fileinput,
it's a pretty big complicated
HTML tag that's being returned.
So there's like an outer div,
which is the actual Shiny input
container that
you'll see around.
A lot of Shiny input functions.
And that's just kind of
a class to let the Shiny
JavaScript know like hey,
this is an input container
that has input value that we
should send back to the server,
that you could access
in the server code.
But there's all this sort
of complicated markup.
And then finally, at
the end of the day,
there's an input tag that is
the actual HTML element that
enables the file uploading.
So essentially, we have this
accept argument on file input
that gets routed to this accept
attribute, the input tag.
So we have this kind
of general problem
with a lot of Shiny
input functions,
where we're basically
wrapping HTML tags.
And in some cases,
you might want
to customize certain
attributes on particular tags
on this return value.
And we might not sort
of out of the box,
provide you the tools
to be able to customize,
like a very particular attribute
on a very particular tag
in this return value.
So this person was kind of
requesting, like hey, there's
this capture attribute on
and HTML input tag that
allows you to enable
the front facing camera
on a mobile phone.
So this would allow him to kind
of do like a facial recognition
thing or allow somebody to
capture a video of themselves
in then upload it
to a Shiny map.
And we've been working hard
on tools to basically allow
you to more generally take
the return value of something
like file input and target
a very particular say
HTML elements like the input
element within this return
structure, and do something
like append an attribute, which
is effectively what this
user is asking for is hey,
could you add an
argument to file input
to basically
customize the capture
attribute on this input tag.
So we're trying to
avoid going down
this sort of rabbit hole of
trying to cover every HTML
attribute on every sort of Shiny
UI function you could imagine,
and providing better tools for
doing this sort of thing, where
this user could instead of
just having the file input,
here basically, do something
like this where instead
of having--
this is the return
value where I have
this input where it's a
type text plus form control
placeholder read only--
And input above it, as well.
Yes, this is the actual
input that's relevant.
Good.
Pointing that out.
We can use this tag
append attributes
which effectively does some
CSS look magic to say--
within this HTML
structure that's
being returned by this
first argument here,
find the first input tag.
So it'll go in and find this
input tag here, and append
an attribute of capture user.
So that's adding this part here.
You could even do--
because it selected
actually both input tags
because there's no
distinguishing marker,
we could do id foo on the CSS.
Right.
The CSS selector-- this--
when I just type out
input, it's basically
going to look for a tag
name of inputs, that's just
kind of how CSS selectors work.
But there is some
special characters
that you can add
to CSS selectors,
where I could tag on a
hashtag or pound sign.
And then an id name.
So it's very pointed out,
I could do pound sign who.
And that would make
sure that instead
of the selector matching
both input tags,
notice how the capture
users only being
added to this input with an id
of foo is instead of this one,
as well.
So, yeah with tag
append attributes,
this is actually a
fairly recent feature
that we've added to
tag append attributes.
In the past, you've
had two kind of--
maybe some of you have
already done something
like this, where if
you actually look
at the structure like the R
representation of this HTML,
it's a big mess of
complicated list structures
that you get back.
And there's a very good
reason why we do this.
It's by having like an actual
formal structure to these HTML
tags, it allows us to compose
them in interesting ways,
and do sort of magical things
like this tagAppendAttributes.
But this is not something you
want to work directly with.
So like, way early
on in HTML tools
you might have had to
do something like $x.
Let me reach into the children
of this top level div tag,
and then look at
what's in there.
It's a list of three, where
the first list is a label,
the second list is a div
that holds the input tag.
So let me actually reach
into the second's child's.
And I actually want to get
into the children of this div,
so now I'd have to do this.
And now I'm getting closer to
getting to this actual input
that I want, but now I need
to reach into this first item,
get into the children.
So as you can see
here, this is not
something you want to actually--
part of what inspired
some of this work
as we've seen a lot of code
out in the ecosystem doing
this kind of stuff
to do custom UI work.
And we wanted to make
it a lot less confusing.
How to do something like this.
Also make your code a lot less
brittle to breaking changes
that we make to kind
of the HTML that we're
returning in these functions.
So I've had to go out and
actually fix cases like this,
because we want to just
slightly tweak the actual HTML
that we're returning.
Or this is like making
very strong assumptions
about the relative
ordering of these tags.
And working with an API,
that's like not super public
and something we don't
really want to encourage
you to actually be doing.
So it's a lot better
to like actually
reach in and get that subset
of HTML that you're looking for
and modify it using
something like this.
Yeah, like placing a
needle within a haystack
in a very specific
location versus rummaging
through and going eh, I
hop, and then leaving it.
And so actually what
powers this CSS selector
argument and the ability
to kind of subset
down, find a particular
subset of this HTML
and then modify it, is
powered underneath the hood
by sort of a lower
level tool that you can,
if you're kind of a power
user and need to do something
a little bit more
sophisticated than something
like tagAppendAttributes
would provide.
We also have this
API called tagQuery.
And if you've ever used
jQuery in JavaScript,
this API will look very
similar to what you already
do with jQuery.
So we're not really
inventing a new wheel here,
we're just kind
of borrowing some
of the best ideas
of what makes jQuery
or what made jQuery
such a great project.
And you can find
this article here
at rstudio.github.io/htmltools.
This is a fairly new
website, and we only
have one article as of now
that gets into tagQuery,
but hopefully we'll get some
more documentation surrounding
HTML tools.
And if you're kind of confused,
like if you haven't really
heard of HTML tools
before, HTML tools provides
kind of the HTML
foundation for Shiny.
So when something
like fileinput returns
all of this HTML
structuring all of that,
all of those data structures
and that writing of HTML logic
is all done by each, this
sort of lower level HTML tools
package.
And you might have never
had to do something
like library HTML tools
before, even if you've
written custom HTML because
Shiny re-export functions
from this package.
So you might have written
like library Shiny
and then like create a
custom, HTML div or something
like that, because you get those
functions when you load Shiny.
But if you load
HTML tools, you'll
get some other functions like
tagQuery, tagAppendAttributes.
Some other functions for
doing like lower level
HTML tool thing or HTML
things that not a whole lot
of Shiny apps will be doing.
So with tagQuery,
the main idea is
that you can pass it either
a tag object, like a div,
or equivalently something like
the return value of our inputs.
I could pass directly
into tagQuery.
And there's two main components
to this return structure.
One is this-- it's actually
a class with methods.
So this is showing you.
If I called the all
tags class, I basically
get the return value that
I fed into this tagQuery.
So it might not be clear why
it's set up this way right now,
but eventually we're going
to like modify the input
value essentially in
this tagQuery object.
And then the other method is
this selected tags method,
which will allow
me to do something
like if I want to find
all the input tags,
essentially what we had
before with CSS selector
equal to input, the equivalent
way of doing this with tagQuery
is to say dollar find input.
It's not going to update
the all tags output
of this tagQuery object,
but it will essentially
subset down the selection
from being by default
the input that I gave it.
It will update the selectedTags
to both of the input tags.
So, now I could do
something like change
a call to selectedTags.
And now I have a
list of like two
containing both
of the input tags
that I might want to
do something with.
And I don't think I can
just kind of on a whim
explain better what tagQuery
where actually provides
than sort of this vignette.
So I do recommend
reading through this.
But kind of the
first portion of this
is all about this
like fine method
and similar methods
like children.
Where fine will find, you
know, traverse essentially,
all of the descendants
of the top level tag,
and find all
occurrences of HTML tags
that match the CSS selector
that you've given it.
So that's why I was
able to use find here
and it traverses everything,
and it reaches in
to like several descendants
down into this input tag here.
But if you wanted to do
something like for some reason,
only consider the
direct children,
which would be this label
div and this other div.
If I search for
children, there's
going to be no selection
associated with that.
That matches the input, right?
But if I wanted to
find a label tag,
there is a direct
child label tag here.
So that will match
on this label.
So in the case of an
action button like,
it's a simple like
one single button tag
which allows us to kind of
design this function interface
as routing all additional
arguments that you might want
to provide to this button tag.
So that allows you to do
things like, my action
button with an idea
of who the label here.
And that creates
this button HTML
with an id, the type,
and some default classes
to give its like default
bootstrap styling.
But say I want to add like a
custom inline style of like I
want to increase the font size
to basically two units of line
height, you can do something
like that with action button
because it basically is like
doing the lower level tags
dollar button, and providing a
style to that directly since we
sort of take dot, dot,
dot, and route it directly
to the tags button.
It's essentially
the same interface.
So in the case of
action button, it's
a very thin wrapper
where you don't really
need this sort of ability
to take the return value
and then modify attributes.
You can just do that
in one shot directly
when calling action button.
And you can send to this--
again is just kind of taking
any sort of input value
and feeding it into button.
If I wanted to, I could pass
another tag object into that,
and like I don't create
just an empty div.
Well, actually that's-- or icon.
I think I'd have to
explicitly say icon is no.
What is that?
Width.
So that is kind
of an unfortunate
thing about the
way this is set up
as you would have to make sure
like, what was happening here
is this tag scalar div
instead of going into the dot,
dot, dot here, since I
hadn't specified an icon.
It was treating it like
the third argument here.
But if I wanted to
take a tag object
and have it run through
this dot, dot, dot.
I could fully specify
those and make sure
that it's going to the
dot, dot, dot there.
And it shows up in my HTML.
Again like the tagQuery,
append attributes,
the CSS selector stuff
isn't super useful for this,
but it's more useful
in a case where
you have like a lot of like big
complicated HTML tag structure
and you need to get at a
particular subset of that.
We did basically just
cover with the tag,
and tagAppendAttributes.
So you have the ability to find
subsets with this CSS selector.
And then ability to
append attributes.
But there's more that you can do
than just appending attributes.
You can also do things
like append children.
So and you'll notice this
other append function
also has a CSS
selector argument.
So you could do a
similar thing where--
again, here's my fileinput.
If I wanted to say insert
another div within this input
group, I could search for
a class of input group
and append a child
tag just a div.
And I'll just give it a
class of my custom class.
And I should load--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Oh, thank you.
And now I actually
get this div of class,
my custom class
inserted by default
I guess in as like the last
child within this input group
tag.
So kind of like,
there's basically
two main ways you might
want to modify the HTML.
Either like mess with
the attributes on the tag
or add or remove tags.
So if it's as simple as wanting
to like add an attribute,
or modify an
attribute, or append
a single child
like this, you can
use these sort of
higher level tag
append child or
append attributes.
But as some of these
examples get into-- you
can use this tagQuery to do
more sophisticated stuff.
And let me try to
find an example of--
You can do like
remove class and class
with like button success
instead of button default.
Right.
Yeah, so let's try out tagQuery
with this action button.
So by default, this button
tag is going to be selected.
And as Barret was saying--
let me actually save this.
An object called BTN.
And then when I
type dollar, I'll
see all of the available
methods on this tagQuery class.
So we've already seen stuff
like find and children.
There's also siblings
parent, and parents,
and this kind of helps you
traverse that tree, where say,
you went to a particular
subset but then
you actually want to go back to
a parent or find a sibling tag.
You can use those methods.
But he was mentioning--
maybe I want to for some reason
take off this BTN default
class, I could do something like
remove this BTN default class.
And this will actually
modify the BTN object.
And we do that for
performance reasons.
That's why this is kind of
like-- even like a lower level
developer, kind
of more developer
facing tool than this API where
it's not modifying the input
object here, it's giving you
basically a copy of that input
value as its return value.
Whereas using tagQuery
more directly like this
actually will modify the
input tax that you give it.
So, yeah, So now I've
removed BTN defaults
and now I could add a
class of say BTN success.
And now it's appended
to the end here.
And maybe to make this a
little bit more motivating,
I'll just show you what
this, something like this
would actually do.
Where that-- it's interesting.
I thought by default
actually it was going
to come up as a blue color.
But that is only going to
come up as a blue color
if I add a class of BTN primary.
And that is a Bootstrap
specific thing
where again this is kind
of like a hard to discover
sort of feature where
Shiny comes with bootstrap,
and Bootstrap has these
sort of semantic CSS classes
where this BTN and BTN default
like gives that default
sort of white coloring
with a border around
it based on bootstraps defaults.
But if you add an additional
BTN primary class, that
will give it this sort of blue
background and border color
that makes it kind of pop out.
So once you kind of aware
of those kind of things
and like more familiar
with how bootstrap works,
or if you're using some
other framework with Shiny,
knowing about these
kind of tricks
to like add or remove
classes from the return value
will help you kind of
be able to leverage
kind of the scaffolding
or the high level
like widgets that
Shiny provides to you,
but also be able to do like
some more custom theming, things
with it.